Let me show you how I taught syllabication with magnetiles.
If you don't know what syllabication is,
is how you break down words into their syllables.
And the number of syllables is determined
by how many vowels there are in a word.
The exceptions being vowel teams in silent e.
But for this activity, we're focusing on open and close syllables,
and how to determine where we're gonna split them.
So on my large square magnet tile,
you could also use four small square tiles.
I wrote a two syllable word,
breaking in two different ways.
One way with an open syllable first,
and the second being with a closed syllable. First,
my daughter read them both ways and decide which one was correct,
covered up the one that was wrong with triangle tiles.
Doing this activity with familiar words
helps them to hear the difference.
And it's such an important skill to practice,
so they can decode longer and harder words later.
And when they know the rules,
they can become confident readers.